You're the most wanted and hated
man on the planet.
Consider this a preview.
Nick.
I'm going to make sure
you get the whole show.
Nick Fury.
My war is set in motion.
This is the extinction of the human race.
So you are responsible for all this?
I think I came back here
after everything you've lost.
Do you still have any fight left in you?
The only power I have
was planted between my ears
by a single mother.
That ain't enough.
I don't know what hope we have.
You're out of moves, Fury.
This is a ticking time bomb.
You've got to figure out which side
you're on.
Marvel Studios
Secret invasion
You going to shoot me?
Maybe.
Well, probably.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, Marvel dropped a trailer
for the last couple of episodes
of Secret Invasion
There's a whole bunch of new scenes
Easter eggs. So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Gist.
In general, the series is meant to help
set up the Marvel's movie,
which is happening later this year.
And in addition to that, what's happening
with Captain America four soon,
with Thunderbolt Ross becoming U.S.
President, Val Restarting the Weapons
Plus Program, Creating this Entry,
creating the Thunderbolts generally
setting off Marvel Phase Five's Dark Reign
era because it's kind of the progression,
the way things happen in the comics.
You go from Secret Invasion,
then you go to dark rain with the villains
start to come to power.
The difference is the comic book
Secret Invasion
is that you have all the heroes,
like all the Avengers, all the X-Men,
all the Fantastic
Four characters, Spider-Man characters,
all fighting together
to get rid of the Skrulls,
even the villains of all those different
heroes fighting to get rid of the Skrulls.
It is Norman Osborn who takes credit
for killing the Skrull
queen, who in the comics
was leading the secret invasion.
That's how he winds up
winning favor with the U.S.
government and coming to power.
He takes over shield.
It takes over all of Iron Man's assets
and kind of sets off this Dark Reign era.
the MCU version of that
will be a little bit different.
Like we don't have a Norman Osborn
inside the MCU right now.
The last Norman Osborn was in Spider-Man.
No way home,
and he went back to his universe.
they're mostly giving that storyline
to Thunderbolt.
Ross in Val.
so we'll talk a little bit
more about them at the end of the video.
But just starting with the new footage
here, we have Nick Fury versus Skrull.
Rhodey Well, it looks like the President's
hospital, look.
I'm assuming
after the end of last week's episode,
he just took the president to the hospital
to get more treatment.
it looks like Skrull.
Rhodey in the Secret Service arrive
at the hospital in Skrull.
Rhodey is trying to make them think
the Secret Service think that Nick Fury
is really trying to kill the president
when it's really actually him.
one of the big things with
this is they have to actually out him.
Look, he has to turn into his Skrull form
in full sight of the Secret Service
and the president so that they realize
that he really is the Skrull,
technically, a female Skrull, too.
But that doesn't really matter.
lot of people are wondering
if that's actually going to wind up
being the Skrull queen.
I don't think that's the case.
They did reference
the other Skrull emperor
that was on a completely separate planet,
like Talos said,
that they did have a Skrull emperor.
He was still alive.
He had a completely separate
set of Skrulls that served him,
but they were in a completely different
part of the universe,
for the most part, like the Million
Surviving Skrulls from their original home
planet Skrullos, or now on Earth.
They're just a small group of them
with the former Skrull emperor
still school emperor, technically
in a separate part of the galaxy.
my guess is they might reference them
during the events of the Marvel's movie
in more of the space based movies
like they do have a plan to do
the Nova character.
Eventually there'll be more space
based movies in general,
even though they're not going
to do Guardians of the Galaxy for That's
a whole separate thing to Rocket's do.
Guardians team will continue in the MCU
like they'll keep coming back, but
it'll be like the Guardians of the Galaxy
appearing during Avengers Infinity War.
In Avengers Endgame.
But they'll show up in other people's
movies.
there's a new scene of Sonia Bosworth
Union Jack taking
Nick Fury to his gravesite, talking
about why he left Earth, why he came back.
does he still have fight left in him?
The idea is obviously, yes,
they've kind of alluded to this
like there was trauma
that he was dealing with.
Like he just needed a break in general.
They had a joke about it
during Spider-Man, far from home,
like he was literally and metaphorically
taking a vacation on the Skrulls
Space station, the saber space station.
Just call it a mental health vacation.
And he's finally come back
like he probably should have come back
sooner than this.
There's a new scene of him
talking about his mother
when he's getting his gear
from his secret stash at his gravesite,
more references to his childhood.
He hasn't talked too much about his mama,
quote unquote, saying
the only real thing that his mother gave
him was his brain.
And he didn't have a father
growing up like a single mother
It sounds like his father either died in
what would have probably been
the Vietnam War, just based on the way
they're moving the timeline.
And when all these wars
would have happened,
or maybe his father died in some separate
event
after he was born back in the sixties
or he left the family.
Maybe he'll mention
more about his father eventually.
But it sounds like he was closer
to his mother growing up.
when they started showing off
the early footage of the series,
a lot of people assumed
that they were actually going to show us
what happened to his father
in this tombstone would be for Nicholas
Fury, senior, and he's Nicholas Fury Jr.
And based on the way they moved
the timeline of all the characters,
maybe they just say that
it was his father, Nick Fury, senior,
who actually fought
with the Howling Commandos
because in the comics
it was actually Nick Fury
who fought with the Howling
Commandos and Captain America.
when he says if his brains aren't enough
to stop the skrulls
and the world is doomed,
that's also probably part
of their justification
for not doing a more comic book.
Avengers Level Secret Invasion
with all the Avengers characters X-Men,
Fantastic Four, basically all the major
Marvel characters Making Secret Invasion
more of a movie Avengers level event,
the $500
million version of Secret Invasion,
although reportedly they spent over $200
million making the series, which seems
kind of crazy,
but that's probably because of
some of the pandemic protocols
he finally puts the iPads back on.
That's probably part of the metaphor
that the old school,
Nick Fury, is finally back like fire and
brimstone, end of the world is upon us.
Nick Fury.
Time to assemble that new Avengers team.
Finally Reportedly,
We're going to see some teasers for that
during the Marvel's movie,
but mostly with the young Avengers.
I think there's going to be a post-credits
scene
that will set the young Avengers
team and Ms..
Marvel trying to go around
and put together the younger heroes.
I don't know if Nick Fury is supposed
to appear in Captain America four,
but I think that's
when we're getting our first teaser
for like the full blown new Avengers team.
They won't actually put it together
in Captain America four.
They'll just be a teaser for them saying,
okay, it's time to finally put together
that new team,
There's a brand new scene of G'iah
finding one of the secret warehouses.
The people that they've taken over,
mostly world leaders, people
in critical positions of power,
the Skrulls secret invasion
technically
already happened a long time ago,
but it's kind of a running joke during
the series
is that it's called Secret Invasion.
But the Skrulls took over
during the five year time jump.
that's when their secret invasion
actually happened.
They'd already taken over all these world
leaders positions at the beginning
of the series that was the whole argument
that Gravity had with the council.
It's like we're already in positions of
power, like we already control the world.
Why do we want to mess this up?
the evil skrulls beat
was that they wanted to be able
to walk around in broad daylight
in their true Skrull form.
And that was sort of the other shoe
dropping like
that would have actually led to all out
war. no.
That's basically
what Gravik is trying to do.
Firing this Russian nuclear missile.
That's his literal
and metaphorical nuclear option.
Now, his plan to kill
the president has failed.
it's only a coincidence that in real life
there's an ongoing war
that Russia has been waging on Ukraine
this new scene of G'iah
meeting with Nick Fury,
who calls them on his plan
to stop Gravik and the Skrulls, like,
what are you actually going to do
to stop them?
There's so many of them
and they're all super Skrulls now,
when he gets super pissed here,
asking this person
which side that they're on, he's
probably talking to his wife
because remember, his wife actually
was working with Gravik since the snap,
but she's since turned sighs
and now gravity side wants to kill her,
they haven't paid this off yet.
But I'm assuming just because of the way
she was interested in him
when he was a child,
she became kind of like a surrogate mother
to him.
And Nick very kind of became
like a surrogate father.
And that's why there's so much concern.
That's why Gravity hates Nick Fury
so much more than any of the other humans.
A lot of people also wondering
if Nick Fury actually
does have a biological child
with his wife.
You're like a half human, half
spoiled child.
If he did, it probably died after birth.
I'm assuming that there is no actual Nick
Fury child in present day,
there's a new scene of G'iah
with his wife attacking the Skrulls
not sure where they're at in this scene.
Then we see one of the super Skrulls
freaking out and then grabbing Hawking out
or using his cool obsidian powers
that he's just given himself
to go after Nick Fury inside their base.
technically, they're basing these powers
on the original powers
of the super Skrull in the comics,
which were based on the Fantastic
Four's powers.
So would be the thing
that they're referencing here.
but I think
because of the pedigree in the MCU
and the way things have gone,
they're also referencing Hulk Powers
to the only Fantastic Four power
we haven't seen is something mimicking
the abilities of the Invisible Woman,
and that would be the Frost Beast POWERS.
Maybe we'll see that in episode five.
Or maybe they're saving that
for the actual finale, Right now.
My guess is that they'll just say that
either has camouflage
abilities in
that would be like their version
of the invisible woman's powers
turning invisible.
she can also create forcefield.
So technically that would work too.
There are probably
a couple other Fantastic
four references loosely in the background.
The last couple of episodes.
We won't see the MCU team
show up for a while.
There's a rumor that it's actually going
to start out
as a period piece movie with them
being lost in time back in the 1960s,
paying off that doctor
Strange multiverse of madness, Easter Egg
At some point during the movie,
they'll find a way back to present day.
They'll time travel the present day
before the events of Avengers
five Qing Dynasty.
part of the idea in the future is
they want the new version of Reed Richards
to be like a big central figure
that rallies everyone together,
like a big Avengers level character.
one of the problems right
now, though, is like the biggest fan,
favorite character, Lincoln,
the most popular character
that they still have around
who's an Avengers
level person would be Spider-Man,
but he's still just entering college.
Like he's not quite there, not quite ready
to lead all the Avengers, Normally.
Had Chadwick Boseman not passed away,
I would say that Black Panther
would be the new leader of The Avengers.
But. In his absence, Reed Richards
would be like the next best person to go
to. doctor Strange is also probably one of
the biggest characters that could do it.
But he's kind of a loner, mostly like he
works with the Illuminati, for instance.
He works with the Avengers team.
But it doesn't really consider himself
an Avenger.
Then they'll end the series in a way
that sets up the Marvel's movie.
Probably a post-credits scene
with Captain Marvel or something like that
in the also probably explained
what's going to happen
to the rest of the Skrulls
that are left on planet Earth.
Nick Very will probably get his job back
and go back to the Saber space station
and that will lead right to the beginning
of the events of the Marvel's movie.
other side of this is explaining
how the dark rain era begins.
Like, how does Thunderbolt Ross
become the next president of United States
in one or two ways
Is the president winds up dying here?
The vice president takes over in
Thunderbolt.
Ross is either already the vice president,
or there's another election.
Really Soon after this, the world
finds out about the Skrulls
and Thunderbolt.
Rogers capitalizes on the fear around that
and uses that to win the election.
part of the idea
is that when he becomes U.S.
president, he basically tasked Val
with restarting the weapons.
Plus program.
And she's the person responsible
for creating this entry in what happens
during the Thunderbolts movie.
That'll happen right after Captain America
for cannot wait to see
what they do with this entry in the MCU.
That's going to be crazy.
there's a bunch of stuff happening
this week.
My full Episode
five video will post Wednesday.
Make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
And then the week after that,
they will have Comic-Con.
Even though a lot of studios
have backed out,
there's still going to be
a bunch of stuff dropping.
So I'll do videos for all the big
Comic-Con trailers that do get released,
There'll be a new trailer for the Marvel's
movie the next couple of weeks to.
click. Here for my Secret Invasion Episode
5 Video.
Update the link as soon as I post it
and click here for that new Deadpool
3 Wolverine video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!